they're very bold I'm a lot to handle  it was another night full of drama on  The Bachelor an emotional lace  confronted frontrunner Olivia for  stealing Ben's attention when the 23  year old news anchor already had a rose  keeping her safe who did what you just  did knowing that girls are gonna react I  just think in this situation sometimes  he just you have to go after what you  want then is my he's my man at this  point I want to take him to a secret  spot to kiss him till his lips fall off  like hello wifey lace was stressed she'd  be sent home apparently so I don't know  but the 25 year old real-estate agent  ultimately received a rose the most  shocking moment of the night actually  came from lb who went home after having  second thoughts it's just hard because  it's like I'm interested in him I  haven't gotten to know him well enough  it's really hard for me to prepare I  just don't know if I can do it thank you